gianni y de puedan bienvenido a una vez
más a radio canadá internacional al
servicio en español de radio canadá tu
grupo porque está langai a este viernes
30 de octubre va a lanzar un segundo
disco el nuevo disco del grupo la
medalla salsa brava de que se trata
correcto correctos y muchas gracias luis
por tenernos en tu programa es un placer
para nosotros si el de 30 de octubre ya
va a ser la fecha de lanzamiento del
segundo trabajo de nosotros que se
titula gold diggers bélenkaya salsa
brava y entonces se estamos muy
contentos de poder tener la plataforma y
el foro como para presentar nuestro
trabajo a la prensa
y mediante radio canal internacional
perfecto y en la grabación se llevó a
cabo durante estos últimos meses es
decir se llevó a cabo durante este año
de pandemia y encierro de todo el mundo
correcto nosotros empezamos para hacerte
sincero desde el año 2019 con una
canción salsa dura hasta la muerte que
hicimos con jimmy box el trombonista
puertorriqueño muy famoso y al principio
nosotros teníamos como objetivo hacer un
tipi o sea una versión más corta con
seis números y al final se convirtió en
un disco completo y si es correcto que
seguimos trabajando hasta junio para de
2020 para la grabación de los demás
números que componen el disco eso quiere
decir que estuvieron grabando
presencialmente o a la distancia empresa
es bueno fíjate tú que presencialmente
porque trabajamos con él
nuestro sonidista que se llama rick
campagna y que es mundialmente conocido
muy famoso que además de ser un dj es un
ingeniero de sonido y músico pues él
tiene su estudio aquí y nosotros
grabamos en su estudio pero músico por
músico entonces cada trombón trombón uno
por uno el bajista el piano cada
instrumento instrumento por instrumento
pero si fue en presencial y
acostumbrados a trabajar todos ustedes
en conjunto cómo fue la experiencia de
grabar uno por uno en forma separada yo
te diría que estamos acostumbrados a
trabajar de esta forma ya que con un
impacto que él es el primer disco de
nosotros hicimos lo mismo ese es el
mismo en el mismo proceso yo te diría y
entonces el trabajo que uno lleva en la
tarima mientras estamos en concierto es
muy diferente a lo que se espera del
músico en estudio yo tendría que esto
pasa muy bien porque somos músicos
profesionales y cada uno sabe lo que
tiene que hacer así que no no hubo
ningún problema hasta
decirte que hay muchos números que no
habíamos practicado juntos entonces cada
uno llegó al estudio sin haber escuchado
en el conjunto de la canción como en
conjunto como sonaría en un conjunto
pero esas inyecciones un procedimiento
en un proceso muy natural para nosotros
exigen lo que es además común en muchos
grupos no siempre cuando un grupo o una
banda una orquesta graba están todos los
músicos presentes a veces hay una parte
de orquesta a veces hay un solo músico
que como en el caso ustedes para este
disco hace su parte a cada uno a su
turno es un proceso que normal no es tan
novedoso no es cierto
exactamente exactamente es un proceso
que yo tenía aún más con la pandemia eso
se lleva eso se se hace mucho se hacen
muchos grandes artistas lo siguen
haciendo y yo creo que es bueno es como
te digo muy natural para unos nosotros
no no hubo ningún cambio de estrategia o
de de manera de hacer las cosas con este
nuevo disco
gianni y qué es lo que va a encontrar el
público de nuevo en este segundo disco
de la andaya obviamente le engañe así
que es una orquesta de salsa brava o de
salsa dura como le dicen y entonces la
gente obviamente no habrá ninguna
sorpresa en decir que vamos a escuchar
salsa brava en este en esta en esta en
este nuevo bus pero también este disco
es una buena plataforma para escuchar
nuevos ritmos y escuchar una orquesta
que llama duro muchísimo más y que ya
tiene mucho más cosas que tenía que que
explotar
en términos de ritmos como el bolero
como el cha cha cha cha cha perdón el
boogaloo son montuno que son varios
ritmos que componen la música nuestra y
que van a aparecer en esta en esta dice
en este nuevo producto y para quienes no
conozcan el estilo no estén enterados en
todo caso de qué se trata cuando
hablamos de salsa dura o salsa brava
como tú has dicho de que hablamos de qué
se trata la salsa dura
la salsa hay dos grandes movimientos
digamos que es la salsa dura y la salsa
romántica la salsa dura es un movimiento
que es más de los años 70
es una música muy parecida a la música
de lo que se hacía en la fania all-stars
donde teníamos la seria cruz sector lago
willie colon es una salsa más rítmica
más con más velocidad con arreglos muy
a mí me gusta es decir agresivos porque
lo son pero mucho más rápida una salsa
mucho más rápida mucha más mucho más
agresiva y este hay que contextualizarlo
porque en los años 70 esta música era la
utilizada como un modo de identificación
social y de reivindicación también para
los la diáspora latinoamericana en los
eeuu por eso lleva tanta fuerza por eso
cantar tanto movimiento tanta brutalidad
a la hora de tocarla
y también quien es bueno en la salsa
romántica que yo te diría que
tito nieves la india cantante es así
se desarrollaron en este en este
movimiento que es la salsa en el caso de
tito nieves empezó con la salsa dura
pero sigo siguió su trayectoria
trayectoria con él
en la salsa romántica entonces nosotros
es hasta brava si no me equivoco
regularmente ustedes tienen 12 artistas
12 componentes es esto una riqueza o una
complicación porque además son personas
que son de distintos orígenes incluso en
algunos casos de distintas lenguas
maternas es esto una riqueza o una
complicación o ambas cosas a la hora de
componer de elegir el repertorio
obviamente es una riqueza es una riqueza
y ese y este es el producto de las alzas
en la salsa
hay muchos es un condimento que lleva
que conlleva muchos ingredientes y eso
lo tenemos también en la música nuestra
y está estas culturas diferentes
enriquecen mucho a la forma de tocar de
componer la música de escribirlos
obviamente somos 12 personas es muy
complicado en términos logísticos para
llevar un concierto para irse de gira
todo eso pero a la hora de componer sea
es una riqueza definitivamente y una
orquesta con 12 músicos no suena no
suena nada en comparación con uno con
una orquesta que tiene cinco músicos
obviamente entonces todo eso hace que yo
creo que esta riqueza la llevamos y
transparente en el trabajo de trabajo
que hacemos nosotros
el nuevo disco tiene once temas de los
cuales dos fueron compuestos por dos
artistas que podemos considerar
invitados o por lo menos no
participantes regulares de lenga ya
puedes decirme por qué invitaron estos
artistas y qué es lo que aportan al
disco
lo bonito es que fíjate tú que no
invitamos a nadie sino a mí porque es el
protagonista de la nueva general en la
nueva generación salsa dudas a la muerte
fueron ellos que escribieron canciones
para el engaña y eso nos orgullece
muchísimo porque la gente
conoce al producto conoce la banda y
escribe para nosotros entonces tenemos
si una canción del maestro jesús ruiz
de venezuela que un perdón que nos
compuso una canción que se llama una
nueva venezuela y otra que
nos fue compuesta por el jarrón aguirre
el cantante de la orquesta clan esquina
de cali colombia que nos conoce que nos
conocen que no es que nos escribe esta
canción entonces sí son cosas que a mi
parecer son buenísimas para lo que está
porque ya la gente la conoce nos quiere
descubrir mandar y escribir escribir
temas y por qué hacer música de origen
latinoamericano en canadá porque es una
buena pregunta yo yo sinceramente es una
parte muy importante de mi cultura yo
nací en la guayana francesa pero yo
también fui criado por por un padre
cubano que escuchaba mucha mucha música
latina entonces yo te diría que eso es
era natural para mí de estar de estar
repitiendo lo mismo que yo hacía cuando
yo estaba pero no estaba en la guayana
francesa
y yo creo que también aquí es una
plataforma muy bonita para la música
nuestra porque la salsa como estuvo en
los eeuu en nueva york es un una cosa
que vincula entre la gente entonces una
forma de estar en una misma identidad
dentro de una música un género musical
que nos que nos parece muy muy común
para muchos de los integrantes de esta
orquesta el lanzamiento del disco se va
a complementar con un espectáculo que se
va a presentar en línea cuando a qué
hora y al revés de qué plataformas sí
claro
estaremos difundiendo el concierto el 30
de octubre el 10 de viernes a las 8 pm
hora de montreal
111 en el facebook de nosotros en la
página facebook va a aparecer el
concierto en línea y también en el
youtube de nuestra casa de izquierda que
se llama lula world record' pero si
ustedes se ponen que se conecten a la
página de lenga ya allí entran y lo van
a ver
para disculpe por último estamos en el
mes de la herencia hispana en que ve que
en otros sitios de canadá es el mes en
el cual se celebra el aporte de la
comunidad hispanohablante y
latinoamericana a la sociedad de acogida
lo que desea la sociedad canadiense
puede el trabajo de la orquesta
inscribirse dentro de lo que se llama
genéricamente herencia hispana
obviamente obviamente eso está está muy
claro yo creo que el trabajo de nosotros
responde y corresponde a esta misión que
nosotros como músicos como parte de la
comunidad hispana consideramos como un
producto que es totalmente integrado
está este mes de la hispanidad y tenemos
de hecho el concierto está en la
programación
del mes de la hispanidad entonces
estamos muy contentos contentos por ello
y como siempre digo esta música y yo
quisiera que la gente se acuerde que
esta música no es solamente una música
para la bailan para festejar tiene un
contenido social tiene mensajes
políticos y nosotros tenemos que que es
una forma para nosotros también pasar
mensajes y obviamente la comunidad
hispana aquí en canadá es muy importante
sigue creciendo y aporta muchísimo a la
sociedad entonces yo creo que se merece
el cine se sigue señalando yo respondo
de lengua ya salsa brava muchas gracias
puerta entrevista con radio canal
internacional muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros para anunciar el
lanzamiento de su nuevo disco y
esperamos el tercero hay nada más como
dices tú ves muchísimas gracias
muchísimas gracias a radio canadá por
por siempre tenernos y considerar
nuestro trabajo
y obviamente ojalá que sigamos con mucho
más éxito y mucho mucho más discos
gracias muchas gracias hasta pronto
hasta pronto